this film and this story is different
because it's really grounded in
reality I don't understand what's
happening I think I'm seeing the
future through her Clairvoyance she
understands that she needs to save these
three girls this is an emergency get off
the train it's more of a suspenseful
Thriller that man's trying to kill you
which is unique from anything you've
seen in a superhero movie if you want to
live you have to trust me it has mystery
embedded in the story you don't think
this is weird how we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day it's got psychologically
mind-bending scenarios that you're just
going to be stumped
on let's try that
again Madam web is unlike any other
Marvel movie Julia get
down it's genuinely refreshing get ready
to see a Superhero Movie that's really
different
now you're showing off maybe a
little